I spent a year working in corporate
America and that was enough for me I
suffered through it I test it out I'm a
hard dedicated worker I wanted to do a
good job at my job and I did a fantastic
job the company did not want me to leave
when I gave him my notice
but I told them I had to do this for my
health and my mental sanity I knew that
what I was doing was not good for me and
I knew that what I was doing was not
cultivating my passion so how does
someone step back into their discomfort
zone after being in your comfort zone
for a period of time because of how
uncomfortable a job was so how do you
step back into the discomfort zone so
just feel of that question ma'am and you
know I'm good for you Elmo seriously
like that is awesome yeah because what
happens is if we get too comfortable for
too long we I mean there there's a
parody of the couch potato you know you
think of lay I don't have a New Yorker
cartoon to describe it but you can
imagine what it would look like yeah
dude it's the couch 4head it was
literally eating a bag of potatoes and
and and there's no real growth in that
other than our waist lines
well contentment does not does not lead
to creation mm yeah that's pithy put
that in the that is right yeah but
creation leads to contentment amen oh
yeah and so I think I think the first
thing you have to do is find what it was
the edge of your comfort zone today and
it's gonna be different for each one of
us right
what's the edge of your comfort zone and
step one step beyond that I'm thinking
about I just got one of those those
stationary bikes at home right and I was
going to my initial objective this month
was to write it every day this month
they're in the month of August I have
decided to step back because on the
seventh day I was in so much pain like I
was like I do probably take a one or two
day break on this thing you know because
you're doing a soul cycle class
literally every
for months and so buddy needs to rest
yeah my objective is if I can do it 15
times a month still a lot 15 SoulCycle
sessions and and in one month but what
are you doing you've been to a SoulCycle
class with me before you
they have periods of high intensity its
interval training right you're really
heavy for 30 seconds on heavy heavy
heavy oh my god am I gonna make it it's
20 seconds then uh how am I gonna go 10
more seconds at this at this energy
level right yeah you figure a way to
push through but then what do you have
have you have another 30 second break
it's on and also you find that edge of
it's extremely uncomfortable to be doing
that but you're not gonna do it in
perpetuity because then you're going to
break you go too far beyond the comfort
zone and you break however if you find
that edge and you push hard for those 30
seconds or whatever the equivalent is
but then there's the moment of rest to
step back into the comfort zone like
it's not it's not complete rest you're
still pedaling and you're Cadence's is
lowered but you're still moving forward
your resistance is not zero but it's
still some resistance there and that
resistance actually helps us grow inside
the comfort zone and it prepares us for
that discomfort as well well in quite
literally man like that's what exercise
is about it's about giving yourself
resistance so your muscles can grow so
you're you can have good cardiovascular
health
like growing in a healthy way like quite
literally you have to have the
resistance right and by the way there's
you we were talking about this on the
health problems podcast that I did with
with Chris and dr. wood when we were
talking about so my health problems but
when people do it some of the best sort
of training is really high intensity and
then back you know if you don't want to
just go out and run for two hours
straight
at a medium pace and and he was
comparing it to the the the mental load
the medium cognitive load is what he
called it hmm
where it's the opposite of what Cal
Newport talks about with deep work like
really heavy focus for an hour or two a
day it's you nine or level nine or Tim
you can't do more than an hour or two of
that
and there are a few exceptions fiction
writers seem to be able to do three to
five hours a lot of them but but but for
the most part and you have this heavy
cognitive low but then you have to back
off and you have to go look at a tree or
something for a while so it doesn't
require that that heavy cognition and I
think the same is going to be true here
for Emma and is is you're gonna have to
find that discomfort and then whatever
that is it's a step beyond the comfort
zone it's not pain don't confuse
discomfort with pain you're two
different things we don't want you to
suffer we want you to get a little bit
uncomfortable that's where you're gonna
grow ya going with your bike analogy
it's like being on the bike is
uncomfortable yeah but then it started
become painful right when you weren't on
the bike and there's a clear distinction
we're like oh like this is not growing
this is hurting it's not good for me
right so he's not growing that's another
that's another beautiful minimal maxim
their podcast Sean I a man you know I
want to encourage I'm gonna start small
she's got a practice getting back into
her discomfort zone so does that mean
you know going to the gas station and
asking for a reef free refill on her gas
does that mean public speaking does it
mean writing you know that first song
and singing it in front of you know her
partner a friend I don't know what that
means for her but my point is is that
she can find these fairly banal
experiences they have no real negative
consequences exactly nothing yet not
banal benign benign so these fairly
within up and off yeah hopefully have an
up that good but I can't be below but
doesn't necessarily have to be but yeah
you can find these benign experiments
these these way to practice kind of
being in your discomfort zone Emma and
the more you practice the better you get
at it there I love the talk Jia Jian I
think is how you pronounce his name he
talks about his story was practicing
failure I know I've recommended this
before on a podcast like several several
podcasts ago but we saw him at the world
domination summit I think was back in
2000 and the most min 2013 huh yeah
but anyway he just does a really good
job of talking about how he doesn't talk
about practicing being uncomfortable
what he talks about his practicing
failure but he gives an amazing talk
about how he went out and tried to fail
on
this so he could get comfortable with it
and I think it's a very appropriate talk
for Emma where she could translate his
advice on failing I'm practicing failing
- practicing being uncomfortable right
yeah right yeah and the other thing I'm
thinking about is she left the corporate
world right she left that corporate jobs
something she wasn't passionate about
and she might be struggling with finding
her passion and so I have this article
from the Atlantic it's called find your
passion is awful advice which is very
suspiciously similarly titled - an essay
that I wrote five years ago dude there
is it's a compliment yes it's a very
good comment and but it's actually well
my guess is the author actually didn't
did not generally with with articles
like in and organs like the Atlantic
that author does not get to pick their
own title oh I got you of either some
editor somewhere that picks a title yeah
anyway we did an interview with Cal
Newport it was called follow your
passion a shitty advice right we'll put
a link that in the show notes but also
I'll put a link to this I just wanted to
to read the beginning of it to maybe
point you in the right direction here in
a Carol Dweck a psychology professor at
Stanford University remembers asking an
undergraduate seminar recently how many
of you are waiting to find your passion
almost all of them raised their hand and
got dreamy looks in their eyes she told
me they talked about it quote like a
tidal wave would sweep them over sploosh
huzzah it's accounting that's the thing
like yeah I mean very rarely as
someone's I found my passion it's
accounting right yeah
although we've talked about Khan or our
accountant he seems to be really
passionate about accounting would they
have unlimited motivation for their
passion they nodded solemnly I hate to
burst your balloon and she said it
doesn't usually happen that way
the article goes on to cite a bunch of
studies and references I'm gonna well
have Sean put a link to in the show
notes but let's talk about it's like the
reason why everyone's nodding their head
like yes I'm always gonna be motivated
is because we do have this saying in
Western society about
if you find something you love to do you
never have to work a day in your life
and there's somebody out there who's
probably like yeah that's my life and I
get up and I don't feel like I ever have
to go to work and I love what I do but
that is a veteran's over there raising
his hand you know and and and but Jordan
is an exception to the rule right like
that is not that is not the rule it
going back to the expectations that we
set for ourselves like that expectation
can really be detrimental to us it's
it's not it it's it is uh it's not good
to have that expectation and I'm arguing
that having that expectation is actually
really really harmful to someone it is
because it presupposes that you were
born to be a nurse or an astronaut or an
accountant or whatever it may be there
is not one thing that is going to be
passionate and by the way the thing that
you're if you do find something that you
can cultivate into a passion you may not
be passionate about it for the rest of
your life yeah absolutely
it might change all together for me
fiction writing was was the the prime
example I'm still really passionate
about writing but I always thought like
that's what I would do for the rest of
my life and I left the corporate world
like fiction writing was the thing and
then now that's what I wanted to do and
I haven't in earnest written any
published any fiction since 2012 yeah
and I haven't written a whole lot that's
publishable since then I couldn't I
couldn't honestly say well I'm a fiction
writer because I don't write fiction
right I and it's not the thing I'm
curious about anymore it is a thing I
was really curious about in my twenties
and I followed that curiosity but guess
what that curiosity led me down a
different path to another curiosity but
if I were to have found my passion then
it'd be something I could never leave
and I couldn't be doing this right now I
couldn't be helping people solve their
problems via a different medium whether
it's podcasting or writing on a blog or
making our next documentary I couldn't
do that if I was so fixed on I've
already found my passion you know or
something worse might happen to when we
have that expectation we find something
that we really like we really enjoyed
doing like writing for example and then
all of a sudden you get to a point where
you're like man this feels like work oh
I must not really be passionate about it
I mean so having that expectation of I
find something I love I get up I don't
work a day in your life
and then you find something you like and
then you realize like oh wow this is a
little bit of work I could you know make
someone just shrug off that time and the
energy that that they wanted to put into
that passion but you know just realizing
that yes you are going to have to work
like you were going to do to you and I I
just not anything else I'd rather be
doing like what we're doing is is
amazing and I wake up every day grateful
for it and I still feel like there are
days where like we work our asses off
well it reminds me on our we did a
patreon livestream we do a monthly
patreon livestream for the patrons and
one of the questions on the last one was
about if you had a year left to live
what would you do with that year what
would you different do differently and
it's actually a question I've asked
myself since 22 2011 yeah um it's a yeah
and I wouldn't do anything differently
because I'm already living my life how I
would live it if I just had the rest of
this year left to live yeah now when I
may be adjusts in particular and move
some stuff up around yes but the end
result of the year would be would be the
same and you and I had this conversation
like what the hell happened in 2006 and
and it was like I don't really remember
what happened in 2000 was that the year
that the promotion or Jeptha I don't
remember and you were like well there
was alcohol and drugs involved but I
that wasn't just 2006 and and like the
point is like now ever since making this
decision living living life one year at
a time because I don't have some
grandiose 10-year plan like well here's
where I'm gonna be ten years from now no
I know what we are going to focus on for
the next year because you and I talked
about we have these conversations we're
gonna grow together this way and we
adjust accordingly but we know we're
gonna do them but we can also look back
and say hey remember in 2010 when we
started the website remember in 2011 we
published our first book to you number
2012 during the holiday happiness tour
you remember 2013 when we moved to
Missoula and started a publishing
company number 2014 when we did the
hundred city tour do you remember in
2015 we did the word tasting tour and
finished filming the documentary do
myrrh in 2016 we released our
documentary remember in 2017 we started
yeah and you have all of these different
each year we have this thing that we can
look back on and say all our resources
our time our attention our money our
skills yeah yeah it was all focused on
on this major project everything else
would have focus on that and so we're
doing something meaningful because we
did focus on it and and I think that's
where we're emma has to be right now is
how is she going to use those resources
don't don't wait around to find your
passion it's find your curiosity what
are you interested in right now and then
and then move in that direction we
really need to come up with a new city I
want to rephrase the if you find
something you love to do you never work
a day in your life let's try and
rephrase that right now so maybe the
saying should be find something that you
don't mind working towards yeah there's
something there man there's another
saying that we have to start putting out
into the world that just sets the red
expectation of of cultivating a passions
hard work right right you're finding
something that finds something that is
worth working your ass off for yeah yeah
that's good we can we can work toward
something pithy here yeah here you pick
the best pithy
the best pithy tweet their podcast Sean
and put that out there and add forum
dashes to it
you